vidéaste amateur aller trop prusse en
ligne de mire elle avance dans borgia
mka à 40 kilomètres de kiev quand
soudain
l'un des tanks à repérer l'ukrainien qui
se réfugie au plus vite
d'autres vidéos vérifiées par la
rédaction des observateurs témoignent
des ravages des bombardements sur active
notamment ces zones résidentielles une
habitante reste inconsolable devant une
victime
sur le sol sans neiges s'entremêlent
tandis que les sirènes des pompiers
laissent place aux sanglots des enfants
personnes proches de la crimée sur cette
vidéo vérifier par les observateurs de
france 24 la place de la liberté prend
des allures de tiananmen un homme
agitent des drapeaux aux ukrainiens face
à des chars russes d'autres les
rejoignent pour défier les soldats du
kremlin
à kiev où les sirènes continuent de
retentir
les habitants se cache toujours dans les
coursives du métro creuser des dizaines
de mètres sous terre le siège pèsent sur
le moral de chacun
il y à de lourds bombardements la tour
de télévision à côté de cette station a
été touché des gens s'inquiètent mais
les employés du métro nous aide beaucoup
il apporte de l'eau et de la nourriture
on pourrait dire que cet abri et plus ou
moins confortable mais tout le monde a
peur surtout les jeunes enfants
une explosion a retenti mercredi soir
près d'une gare de kiev laissant
craindre aux autorités une panne de
chauffage dans la ville alors que le
thermomètre passe régulièrement en
dessous de zéro degré